hi there Steve Kaufman I haven't done a
video
the videos are sort of sporadic now
because my iMovie is acting up so
whenever it looks like it wants to work
then I will do a video today I want to
talk about Korean we have launched
Korean at link and it's gonna be very
very interesting I have decided to go
back to learning Korean about four years
or so ago before I started Russian I
spent about six months I really threw
myself at Korean and I have a confession
to make
I am a bit of a language addict so
addicts typically spend a lot of money
on their habits and I have in the past
been guilty of spending a lot of money
on my habits back in the 80s when I went
to learn German I went around all the
bookstores in Vancouver secondhand book
stars in bookstores and was able to buy
a lot of inexpensive books to enable me
to do a lot of reading and learning of
German with Korean now that I'm older
and I have a little more income I
actually ended up blowing a whole bunch
of money and I'm gonna show you all the
books that I bought for learning Korean
over during a six month period some of
which I use some of which I whenever I
saw something related to Korea and I
bought it so that I would have it my
intention was to study Korean for
however many years were necessary but I
got bogged down because the content that
was available was so boring all right my
first exposure to Korean when I lived in
Japan I visited Korea and I thought
wouldn't it be neat to learn Korean
so I bought a series of books you can
barely make this out but it says your
Jung
kang-cook Google and there's a you know
boom PO is an old book in itself your
hammer I haven't gotten very far enough
when I can tell you Kisho Kurokawa
Monday and Newmont college it's your
money in other words here the advantage
is that they often show you what the
characters are
helped me of course because I know the
characters so I didn't do much with
these books it was I wasn't very
motivated again I have a tendency to buy
language books and not do much I didn't
do much but I kept them and I went back
to a little bit during the six-month
period when I was in Beijing I bought a
Chinese book because one of the things
that I was interested in was in learning
how the characters are used in Korean
again it's not a very good book lots of
stuff as usual as usual not about Korean
festivals but about the Great Wall of
China the Forbidden City so the Chinese
were promoting Chinese culture to people
learning Korean for some strange reason
I didn't do much with this book no I did
find a book that wasn't too bad
produced here in Vancouver at UBC called
continuing Korean and the best thing
about this book was not the price mind
he was quite expensive was the fact that
the audio was quite interesting so that
the content was kind of fun to listen to
which is very very important lots of
examples I mean I shouldn't be too hard
there's lots of grammar explanations
which I have trouble with but lots of
examples
lots of audio to listen to I listened to
the CD that came in this in the little
of folder here I listened to it many
many many times it was good $50 yeah
probably worth it I did ICML which you
probably can't see but it was terrible
the S&L for Korean is awful the acid
milk for Russian wasn't bad but for
Korean is very boring content and it
doesn't teach you the words which is the
way I like to learn it has the sort of
parallel text and then lots of notes
cultural notes and things like that that
I just find to be a great distraction so
this was a waste of money here is
another thing called a colossal series
called integrated Korean of the
University of Hawaii and it goes
beginner one beginning one beginning -
etc terrible book very unpleasant to
look at full of on this
sorry explanations you know hairlike
pronunciation fricative consonants and
then a you know lips gum Ridge hard
palate soft palate throat liquid nasal
are inclusive I have no idea what all
this stuff means but it just goes on
forever there are six books in all each
one cost twenty dollars yeah I bought
them all what can you do I'm a sucker
you know lots of books didn't amount to
much the most useful book of all was
this little book
colloquial Korean and the other one that
I bought was teach yourself Korea and I
can't seem to find it around the house
anymore
that was kind of useful I was always
because I know Chinese characters you
know Korean through Chinese characters I
bought there was a handbook of Korean
vocabulary that I bought because again
it shows you the characters which helps
me learn the Korean so I don't know 120
to 300 oh I bought a bunch of readers
which were also quite boring College
Korean modern Korean another different
College Korean we had a readings in
modern times Korean literature which was
too difficult for me
Korean reader for Chinese characters but
it only introduces the introduced a very
few characters the one thing about the
this series clear series is you get a
lot of paper for very little useful
stuff lots of exercises fill in the
blanks I don't know a colossal
expenditure anyway now that we have
Korean at link we're taking entirely
different different approach we have
launched Korean we have very little
content in our library we are asking our
members to help us
James over at Korean as it is and I
mentioned the I gave the link to his
blog at my blog my blog is a linguist
that language
he has started giving us some Korean
content again we looked for audio and
text he has helped us translate some of
our beginner content and found some
people to help record this information
so that some strange noise just happen
here so yeah we're starting to build our
Korean library
I am hoping we get more I'm going to
visit with a local Vancouver chapter
that Joomla or the Vancouver subsidiary
of Joomla an elbow to sea we can get
some content from there we're gonna have
to build it up over time but my focus
now is on reading and listening at link
because basically what I want is content
saving words and phrases to my database
and reviewing them and this is where my
money is going now reviewing them in
flash cards on my ipod touch reading on
the internet I have an iPad I have an
iPad so that eventually I will be
accessing all of the content that I want
to study in Korean via my iPad I hope to
be doing my linking on there it's not
yet as convenient as I would like we may
have to do something there we've created
another application which works on the
iPhone iPod Touch iPad whereby you can
listen and read as well as review your
flashcards on those and so I kind of
think that where we're heading is that
this and this together with a community
of people on the web who you know if
someone has a website that's helping
people learn Korean they can
whatever they want there they can have
they can work with grammar explanations
grammar exercises charge money not
charge money we don't care if they want
to if they will give us some content for
our library we advertise their website
we get some content for our learners we
would send learners to them if they do
things differently than we do or even if
they're in competition with us it
doesn't really matter we're quite happy
to - as long as we get some content for
our learners so I think this is gonna be
very interesting we're gonna build up
this community of learners that are
gonna share learning content we want
content other people can do it
differently and I think it's gonna be
interesting in my time will be spent
listening reading and and reviewing and
when I feel strong enough I was beat and
so I'm gonna keep track of how much how
many links I create between now and
December and in December I'm going to
speak with a native Korean because I'm
basically forgotten everything I learned
four years ago except - enough to say a
few words so I'm gonna run out of time
but that's where we're headed thank you